hey what's up Samuel EADS here you know
I'm just getting super sick and tired of
people's ridiculous opinions is
buy-to-let dead I've seen videos on
YouTube of people saying the Bible that
is dead but then when I watch their
video I can't actually make any sense of
the video then just one fond I'm just
struggling here I really want to argue
if someone on my channel unlike a
thoughtful Thursday debate I've got five
reasons why people are saying bye too
late there is it dad no I don't think
it's dead at all and I think I can list
you 20 reasons why it's not dead let me
address the reasons why people are
saying it's dead
these are the reasons number one tax
reasons section 24 which is ridiculous
thing to say but we'll address that in a
minute
number two legislation okay number three
these are the best five reasons I could
come up with if there's any other reason
it's comment below and I'll address them
number three because the media are
saying bad things about landlords so by
Jay is dead because the media are saying
bad things about landlords okay number
four tenants rights and number five the
uncertainty of bricks it so because of
tax reasons legislation the media saying
that we agreed a tenants rights and the
uncertainty breaks it all right so let's
apparently dead what are my thoughts
well let me address these first five
things and then I'm gonna just give a
few reasons as to what I don't think is
dead because right now I think we are
sitting on a gold mine I've been in
property for 11 years I've bought my
first house 11 years ago and I think
that right now is the best time to get
into property certainly over the last 11
years well I think that no all argue
with the fact that there's massive money
to make in property okay so being a
property entrepreneur maybe rent to
rants serviced accommodation or
development buying selling time to
splitting all this stuff we're talking
specifically now about buy-to-let which
is when you buy a house and rent it out
brilliant brilliant by Dylan okay so tax
reasons section 24 that's coming in at
the moment section 24 is saying that you
can no longer claim your mortgage
interest payments as tax-deductible so
what that means is if you are previously
renting out your house for five and open
a month
and your mortgage was 200 pound a month
you've got 300 left now then what be
some expected on that 300 fine but that
300 is what you pay tax on now what
they're saying now what they're phasing
in is to say that you'll pay tax on the
whole rent so you won't be able to
deduct your mortgage interest payment as
tax deductible that's the change
everyone's been talking about this
recently but it this was announced like
in 2016 I don't know why certainly
everyone's talking about it now I guess
they're phasing it in maybe but so
there's all these news articles there
was what I'm thinking jeez this is old
news that's what section 24 is that's
what everyone's talking about when
they're talking about the tax changes
there's actually other tax changes but
they carried on and you can you can read
this online so things like room rate tax
that's going up and there's all kinds of
stuff but we're not gonna go into that
we're just talking about it right now
so why is section 24 these tax changes
why don't they scare me they scare me
because number one if you buy in a
company it doesn't apply I've been
buying in a company for the last two
years now previous dad was an individual
when they announced the tax changes
section 24 they immediately quietly
announced that this doesn't apply if you
buy through a company or by the way they
changed the rules immediately and said
if you buy through a company there will
be no checks to run the company anymore
previously if you buy through a company
when you do buy-to-let they'll do a
million or more checks on the company
they'll want to know all the background
of the company as the company being
trading this long what does it do
watch this turn over what's his figures
as finances now you can set up a limited
company today in 20 minutes and page 17
pound tomorrow you can buy a house
through that company because you as an
individual will be guarantor to the
company and then the new tax changes
don't apply so that apply so people can
stop talking about them the kind of
properties that I own the mortgage is a
little and paid to small I cuz I borrow
rent hi I'll be teaching this for years
I've been doing this for many years I'm
a young guy but I started young bye-bye
low rent high which means that my
mortgage payments might be two hundred
three hundred pound a month and I rent
1500 per a month you know how much just
can all affect me the new tax changes
all the bytes that landlord I
properties all over the country I've got
properties in Wales
I've got properties real far north I've
got many houses in the Midlands
scattered all over the place I'm gonna
get affected on average 25 pounds per
month per property it's not a big deal
why because I'm a smart investor and I
buy right but now I'm just buying
through a company so the tax changes
don't apartheid you for a freaking out
oh my gosh the tax changes then then
will it affect you if you're an idiot
but whenever there's a bad rule change
over here there's always another wall
change over here because the people that
make the rules are the same people that
make money in property section 24
doesn't worry me at all in fact it
excites me what am i excited by the tax
changes because all these people is
amateur landlords that I've got these
houses and they bought these stupid
houses with their feelings not with
their formulas because they wanted to
because the home so that they could
manage it why doesn't why do they need
to manage it and it'd be close to home
because there's a problem that's not
financial freedom it's not running a
business that's not being a smarter
anyway so these amateur investors that
are getting the rent of five hundred
pound a month and their mortgage is four
hundred pound a month because they
bought in Bristol centre because that's
where they live and that's buy-to-let
they'll be hit because now they're
paying tax on the whole five hundred but
they were only making two hundred profit
before all these hundred pounds that
they will make it each month of these
properties has now gone down to fifty
pound or nothing and then my gosh what
am I going to do well what they're gonna
do is they're either gonna sell up which
is gonna be a good thing because it
gives those opportunities or more likely
they're gonna put their rents up a
little bit from 500 to 600 so suddenly
all these landlords are like they're
putting their rents up a bit meanwhile
are buying in a company unaffected but
because they're putting their rents up a
bit I'm thinking what I can put my rent
up a bit so what's happening what's
happened over the last two years is
rents have gone up massively I was
getting like 550 for my three bet houses
around the Midlands a Birmingham Walsall
550 now I get 700 for the same houses in
the last 18 months because of the
section 24 by the way I'm not a tax
advisor okay so speak to your accountant
because he might believe you don't need
to buy in a company section 24 the tax
changes are not bad if you know what
you're doing so that that's the big main
reason people are saying that by sight
is dead number two the next thing is
legislation a lot of people have been
saying their legislations getting really
strict for bita let's hang shimmers
they've said that you need to have all
HMOs of all ice instead of five people
or more I just didn't just big
landlord if you're waiting out good
houses and their and they're safe
and they fit the purpose then what's the
problem
the only problem is if you're trying to
rent out a house that's not fit for
purpose if you're trying to rent HMOs
out and you've got little rabbit run
rooms everywhere and you and you've not
got fire doors and now suddenly it needs
to be licensed Daniel oh no honey it
needs to be licensed they're gonna come
and they're gonna see the mess of the
house then that's a problem but if
you're a good landlord on it I see what
the problem is when you buy a house in
Wales you've got to have a license even
if it's just a small bite in that house
you gotta have a license
what's the problem just get a license
took me about an hour and a half to fill
out a little form to check that I was a
decent landlord legislation is a good
thing because it puts off the amp the
real amateurs and the real rogue
landlords which is a good thing because
then a horrible competition that suck
and give us a good name animal so I've
been lit upon with the legislation at
all
I just cannot see why you would say lay
by till it is dead because of
legislation it's a big deal when you
rent another house as a tenant you want
the house to be safe I just baffles me
number three is that the media are
saying bad things about landlords I mean
jeez the media always bash rich people
you know rich people are greedy
landlords slum landlords like oh I went
on a show on the TV I've been on the TV
many times they've never really painted
me have too bad of a life but I don't
know what to even say about that one
tenants rights and uncertainty of brick
set I've been to things that we don't
know what's gonna happen
tenants rights they've abolished section
21 section 21 is just a way of serving
notice to a tenant and they're gonna
replace it something else but we don't
know what that something else is and
people go alternates rights but we don't
know what that something else is Sam it
breaks it we don't know what's gonna
happen with breaks it I don't know
what's gonna happen with brexit
uncertainty does not mean something is
dead it means that we're uncertain but
Warren Buffett says when people are
uncertain and afraid that's when you
should be really greedy when I started
out in property was the same story
11 years ago there was the credit crunch
and then one was like ah really scared
I'll be pop I was too stupid I was to
not eat I was just behind houses because
that's why big Tom still might come on
my trainer I'm really glad that I did
now you need to be aware I'm not saying
put your head in the sand but there's a
lot of scare mongering going on around
what about the bites that's fantastic
well I told you the reasons what people
are saying is bad and while I think that
they are wrong here's the bottom nerd
okay in England right now there are
foreign investors from Hong Kong
Singapore Australia even America India
China coming in and buying houses too
right now like crazy at the moment in
the UK why well the reason is is because
have a lot of money they're smart
they've looked at their country they've
looked to England and they've gone yeah
it was much better but we're here more
scared all afraid I've got much to say I
haven't got much to say what I'm gonna
say is I'm just gonna continue making
money continue buying houses yes I'm a
property entrepreneur so I'm doing other
stuff as well I'm buying and selling and
I'm title splitting you know all this
sort stuff of training business it's
great I'm also aggressively buying
houses I just bought a house last month
I bought it I refurbished it I pulled
out all my money all of it I'm now
renting it out or making money on it
don't get so freaked out about the tax
oh but what about the tax just worry
about making money and ultimately as I
said before we're on a very small island
the problem here is that we have a
shortage of houses and an overpopulation
of people boating houses
you ain't gonna loose there's no so just
get educated and love like your thoughts
if you want me to debate if somebody
finds the people that are saying bye to
that is dead that have good arguments
and then tag them and tell them that
they are welcome to come on my channel
I'd love to debate them I'm open I just
think they're wrong what are your
thoughts comment below see you next time
[Music]